meet sarah sarah is a sales professional
and a tunngle me user when she wants to
meet with clients
she turns to tumble me because with
tungle me
there are no costly double bookings no
timezone mishaps
and no more email ping pong trying to
find a time that works for everyone
here's how it works john is sarah's
client
sarah emails him the details of an
upcoming project
he wants to book a call to discuss so he
clicks the tunnel of me link in sarah's
email signature
he arrives at her tumblr me page to see
the times when she is free
he clicks to schedule the meeting adds
details
selects a few available times and sends
sarah receives the email invitation she
sees the times john has proposed
overlaid on her own calendar
she picks a time that works and clicks
book meeting
the meeting is automatically added to
sarah's calendar
and john receives an email confirmation
to add to his calendar
it's as simple as that sarah's tumblr me
page
only displays times that she wants shown
as available
she has set her availability from
mornings and afternoons
every monday to thursday she has also
sync tunngled me with her calendar
so that as new events are added to her
calendar tunkelmie will automatically
update her availability
and she won't be double booked sarah has
also chosen to add a photo
contact info and a link to her personal
blog
on her tumble me page she can share the
link to her page
anywhere she connects she adds it to her
email signature
skypes it to clients tweets it to
followers
posts it on her linkedin profile and
even prints it on her business cards
soon everyone is tumbling making
scheduling even easier for sarah
she can search for colleagues in the
temple me directory and add them to her
contact list
she can schedule group meetings by
selecting from her contacts
or adding names to a tungleme url to see
everyone's availabilities overlaid
she can invite non-tunglers to meetings
with just an email address
and they don't have to sign up to reply
she can even schedule meetings from her
iphone or blackberry
and respond to meeting invitations from
any smartphone
and that's how tunnglemee makes
scheduling meetings quick and easy for
sarah
so are you ready to tungle